The critical values for this inequality are x equals 3 halves, and x equals 5.
So this splits the number line into three different intervals. let's pick a
value from each interval and test it. From over here on the left, I'll pick 0.
And if I plug that in, I end up with a negative number over a negative number,
or a positive number which is greater than 0. So yes, this interval checks off.
If I pick a number in this middle region, like three, then they'll end up with
a positive number over a negative number, which makes a negative number, which
is not greater than 0. So this interval does not work. Over on the right,
plugging in six for x does check out. So this region should be shaded as well.
On a number line then, our solution looks like this. With of course, rounded
open brackets showing that 5 and 3 halves are not included. Written as an
inequality then, our solution should be x is less than 3 halves joined with x
is greater than 5.